[Musique]
une plusieurs milliers de personnes ont
défilé ce samedi près du ministère de la
santé a à paris a déçu par le ségur de
la santé ils ont battu le pavé pour
réclamer l'arrêt des fermetures de lits
dans les hôpitaux publics et de
meilleures conditions de travail pour
les soignants leur slogan on veut des
lits des postes pour l'hôpital public
[Musique]
emmanuel macron et mohamed 25 manon
chevet du liban mission accomplie pour
voir le président français qui a tiré
profit de sa visite au moyen orient un
derniers jours à ryad où il a décroché
l'initiative pour aider beyrouth les
aussi réponse le pays du cèdre avec
l'arabie saoudite avant cela la france
on le rappelle a conclu une vente de 80
rafale à abu dhabi
[Musique]
joe biden et vladimir poutine devrait
s'entretenir par visioconférence mardi
il sera question du dossier et craignent
un source de tensions diplomatiques mais
sans aucun doute également de la crise
migratoire qui oppose la biélorussie à
la police
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur arte france à l'appel de
force ouvrière les soignants battu le
pavé du côté du ministère de la santé à
paris ils étaient 6000 selon une source
syndicale 2100 selon la préfecture de
police alors objectif demander l'arrêt
des fermetures de lits et de meilleures
conditions de travail sûres ségur de la
santé a permis des hausses de salaires
c'est trop insuffisant selon le député
dans cette situation où on nous impose
un pass sanitaires et bien on supprime
les lie donc là il y en a cinq mille 700
camps ont encore été supprimées on en
annonce d'autres et c'est parfaitement
incohérent avec la situation que nous
vivons on est dans un monde de procédure
on est en train de casser le métier
soignants alors les plans blancs existe
on enlève de plus en plus des soignants
et ça fait des années que ça dure
bientôt il y aura peut-être plus de
manif y aura plus que des chômeurs
soignons peut-être ou libéraux c'est
parce qu'on veut les l'hôpital public
doit avoir des moyens est actuellement
les moyens du ségur sont insuffisants
nettement ils ont essayé de rattraper le
coup mais ça suffit pas ils le savent
très bien en tout cas le gouvernement le
sait très bien donc je demande à olivier
ferrand et à d'autres comme tous mes
collègues qui sont là d'arrêter de nous
mettre la pression procédurale de
l'europe pour faire des métiers puis
exercé des métiers de bureaucrates la
prolongation à des couvre-feux en
martinique et en guadeloupe
en guadeloupe le préfet a annoncé un
prolongement de 18h à 5h du matin
jusqu'au 7 décembre dans 21 communes
dont pointe à pitre et puis en
martinique l'interdiction de circuler
est fixé entre 19 heures et 5 heures sur
l'ensemble du territoire jusqu'au 8
décembre à cela fait suite aux violences
et aux barrages qui bloquent les
antilles depuis deux semaines un
mouvement social né du refus de
l'obligation vaccinale pour soignants et
pompiers écouter jimmy et les missiles
et sécrétaire départemental unité sgp
police fo martinique et il dépeint une
situation encore très instable dans le
département ultra marin
on parle de se limiter en a parlé de
quelques tirs par ci par là sachez que
si le retour de mes collaborateurs et
moi même parce que étant également
présent c'est un jour sur ces
manifestations il ya eu plus de sentir
des fois barbare par nuit nous savons
très clairement que hâter mouvement les
choses peuvent prendre parce qu'il ya
pas mal de problèmes sur l'île et
notamment le problème et à la sécurité
et là nous l'avons vous très clairement
il ya beaucoup d'armes qui circulent qui
dit armes dit également drogue dit
trafic c'est pour ça que même là où nous
avons des renforts actuellement sur
l'île nous aider à rétablir l'ordre
établir une vie paisible
pour que nous ayons des renforts de
passion des mots forts de manière
pérenne la cinquième vague de convives
continue de déferler sur la france plus
de 50 mille nouveaux cas ont été
enregistrés ces dernières 24 heures
selon les chiffres de santé publique
france est ce qui confirme
l'accélération de l'épidémie de son côté
olivier ferrand a annoncé sur twitter
que 10 millions de français avaient déjà
reçu leur dose de rappel l'objectif que
s'était fixé le gouvernement pour cette
fin de semaine est donc atteint et
c'était l objet de notre décryptage ce
soir nous étions avec laurent alexandre
essayiste et chirurgiens et françois g
en ski médecins spécialistes de santé
publique
la bague actuelle est impressionnante en
nombre de cas grâce à la vaccination est
aussi à l'amélioration de la prise en
charge parce que même si on sait
aujourd'hui que la chloroquine et le
protocole house ne marche pas du tout en
revanche on a fait d'énormes progrès en
matière de réanimation l'oxygène à haut
débit et puis les corticoïdes comme la
dexaméthasone à très forte dose entraîne
un vrai effondrement de la mortalité
donc les énormes progrès qui ont été
faits en réanimation sont qu' on a un
gros pic mais on a aujourd'hui pas
beaucoup de morts le nombre de morts va
monter un petit peu puisque on sait
qu'il ya un décalage entre les
contaminations est mort mais globalement
le bilan il est beaucoup beaucoup moins
grave qu'il ya un an beaucoup beaucoup
moins grave est la vaccination y est
pour beaucoup c'est normal d'être
inquiet par les effets secondaires mais
bon maman a quand même de plus en plus
de recul sur sur les vaccins sont
utilisés maintenant depuis depuis deux
ans a énormément de recul sur les
vaccins de façon générale on le répète
mais bon c'est vrai que la vaccination
c'est pas non plus un outil
thérapeutique de prévention qui est qui
est nouveau donc on est là ont plus ou
moins là on est gage de plus en plus de
données dont convenait de plus en plus
serein sur l'utilisation des vaccins
donc l'inquiétude est lui-même et ça il
faut évidemment la prendre en compte il
faut que les en premier lieu les
soignants et les médecins rassurent
explique prennent le temps d'expliquer
il reste beaucoup de personnes qu'on
peut encore convaincre en expliquant en
prenant l'expliquer donc il faut il faut
continuer
le président français emmanuel macron a
clôturé ce samedi sa tournée express
dans le golfe en arabie saoudite à des
retrouvailles attendues avec le prince
mohammed bin salman trois ans après la
mort du journaliste jamal rachou guy est
le président français a affirmé avoir eu
une discussion sans tabou sur les droits
de l'homme avec le dirigeant saoudien
une rencontre marquée par le lancement
d'une initiative commune pour aider le
liban et la volonté aussi d'apaiser les
tensions diplomatiques entre ryad et
beyrouth causés par l'engagement
saoudien au yémen à mohammed bin salman
et emmanuel mâcon ont discuté par
téléphone avec un ajimi qu'at-il premier
ministre libanais qui a salué un pas
important je cite vers la reprise a des
relations on écoute le chef de l'état
français
sur le liban nous avons ensemble
travailler et nous avons ensuite
ensemble appelé le premier ministre
mikati
il ya quelques instants pour passer un
message clair
l'arabie saoudite et la france veulent
s'engager pleinement
et c'était très clair dans les termes
qu'il a utilisée nous voulons nous
engager pour être en soutien du peuple
libanais notre volonté est aussi que le
gouvernement puisse travailler de
manière normale et donc se réunir au
plus vite et mener les réformes utiles
j'appellerai demain le président à une
fois rentrée à paris mais le message
clair de l'arabie et la franc de
l'arabie saoudite et de la france et
celui ci
nous l'avons conclu ensemble nul ne peut
ignorer les déclarations fortes ir faite
par le premier ministre mikati et je
pense que donc c'est un réengagement de
la relation est aussi un travail à trois
et on va en parler tout de suite avec
michel fayyad il est analyste politique
et financier
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france d'abord au quel
bilan vous faites vous de cette visite
du président français emmanuel macron au
moyen orient et dernièrement donc il a
clôturé sa cette visite en arabie
saoudite pour le président français cela
semble être une mission accomplie
puisque il a obtenu une initiative
commune avec ryad pour votre pays le
liban
oui bonsoir la france a effectivement
joué un rôle très important dans le
rétablissement des relations entre
économique entre l'arabie saoudite et le
liban il y avait une crise qui est donc
été terrible pour le liban qui en fait
exporte à peu près pour 500 millions de
dollars vers l'arabie saoudite en
agriculture en produits industriels et
c'est essentiel pour le liban de sortir
de cet embargo que l'arabie saoudite lui
avait imposé un embargo donc contre
l'autorisation balgau contrôler les
importations les exportations est
également en fait tout ce qui était il y
avait un risque au niveau des 550 milles
libanais qui travaillons dans le golfe
dont à peu près 350 milles en arabie on
va peut-être rappeler les origines de
cette crise diplomatique entre ryad et
beyrouth c'est l'engagement saoudien
dans la guerre au yémen
oui tout à fait en fait c'est un
ministre
libanais au sein du gouvernement mikati
qui nie ce procès riant proches du
président
qui avait tenu des propos contre
l'intervention de l'arabie saoudite au
yémen et mais cela avant même d'être
nommé il était en fête à quai pour ses
propos et je pense en fait est juste un
excellent outil pour imposer des sens
dupont puisque le véritable en fait la
véritable cible pour l'arabie saoudite
c'était en fait le hezbollah dans ce
qu'il considère que le liban et son
contrôle du hezbollah
donc c'est la vision de l'arabie
saoudite est donc l arabie saoudite
cherche t elle à punir le liban post a
en fait c'est tout cela montre qu'il ya
un véritable problème au liban c'est que
il y a en fait différents partis
politiques différents leaders politiques
qui se tournent vers les 3 p et il ya
également des projets erp qui essayent
de simi est libre c'est pour cela qu'il
est arrivé à la neutralité du liban et
neutralité qui doit être positive comme
c'est le cas par exemple pour le
sultanat doman qui est impayée neutre
positif est également une autre réalité
qu'ils soient permanents et reconnu
internationalement comme c'est le cas
par exemple du turkménistan donc il faut
une conférence internationale au niveau
des nations unies pour répondre en fait
faire déclarer le liban un pays neutre
reconnu internationalement
est-ce que après l'entretien entre le
premier ministre libanais emmanuel
macron
le prince héritier mohammed bin salman
la réconciliation elle est véritablement
scellé avec votre pays
je pense pas que la réconciliation un
soin soit véritablement à sceller parce
qu'il ya différents problèmes qui
persistent l'arabie saoudite considère
le hezbollah comme un ennemi et
considère que le liban est entre les
mains du hezbollah donc ce problème va
va persister et continuer mais encore
une fois ce qui est essentiel c'est que
il faut que la souveraineté du liban
soit respecté que l'indépendance du
liban soit respecté que les pays
étrangers cesse de s'immiscer dans les
affaires internes libanaises est
également que les libanais eux mêmes les
politiciens les partis politiques cesse
de regarder vers l'étranger cesse de
demander l'aide de thèmes telles
puissances étrangères il faut que le
liban soit véritablement souverain et
que la neutralité soit appliquée au
liban est reconnu par tous le liban ne
pourra pas s'en sortir sans que l'arabie
saoudite l'iran les etats-unis la france
et ses reconnaissent l'indépendance du
liban reconnaissent la poule
d'indépendance de la politique étrangère
du big bang reconnaissent une neutralité
pour ce pays et qu'en même temps les
libanais arrêtent de demander l'aide de
l'arabie l'est de la france les états
unis l'aide de l'iran l'aide de la
russie et de la chine etc il faut
arrêter il faut qu'aujourd'hui les
libanais reconstruisent de le système pi
6 po ssible michel fayyad parce qu'on
voit bien là l'initiative franco
saoudienne pour justement permettre à
nouveau le liban de de poursuivre donc
les importations qui étaient interdites
par ryad
comment c'est possible comment le liban
peut s'en sortir sans une aide
extérieure on voit que la france est au
chevet du liban maintenant depuis
plusieurs années comment est ce que vous
vous voyez les choses à ce niveau
oui moi quand je dis qu'il faut pas
d'ingérence politique de l'étranger et
qui dans les deux sens quand j'ai dit du
point de vue des pays étrangers vers le
liban et des libanais vers les pays
étrangers ça veut pas dire que je suis
content ned internationale au contraire
je suis pour il ne l'aide financière du
fmi de la banque mondiale et d'un
commentaire par la sonal envers le liban
mais pour cela il faut également une
véritable adoptables changements au
niveau politique et au niveau financier
au liban il faut que le liban s'engagent
dans des réformes de restructuration
bancaire et sans cela il n'y aura rien
il faut qu'il y ait un véritable
changement politique mais pas seulement
chez les ch et la communauté chrétienne
mais également chez les communautés
musulmanes sunnites la communauté
musulmane chiite et la chronique druzes
et autres dons qu'il est il est
important qu'il y ait un véritable
changement à tous les niveaux politique
c'est pour ça qu'il faut des élections
et qu'il faut un véritable changement
donc financier parce qu'aujourd'hui le
liban est une banque au cra ci étant que
cette banque au cra si elle n'est pas en
fait
changé erreurs on lui retire son pouvoir
hors change des choses on pourra pas
arriver à des réformes aujourd'hui vous
parler de najib mikati mais agile mikati
c'est que le communisme le liban oui
mais c'est le deuxième homme le plus
riche du pays le premier temps son frère
il s'est lui-même un banquier le
ministre des finances et est un ancien
de la banque centrale il était membre de
la branche sans faille juste avant sa
nomination comme ministre des finances
et aujourd'hui on entend que les seules
réformes qui kimble qu'il constitue qui
veulent faire pour résoudre la crise
financière c'est vendre les actifs de
l'état au lieu de faire payer en fait
les banques qui sont les laits et la
banque centrale qui sont les véritables
le coupable entre guillemets de la crise
financière au liban en tout cas aller il
ya urgence justement pour permettre au
liban de
se relancer puisque l'économie libanaise
elle est exemple
oui niveau économique c'est terrible
vous avez aujourd'hui le trois quarts
des libanais qui sont qui sont pauvres
et ça va continuer à se dégrader si s'il
n'y a pas des éléphants qui sont
entreprises donc effectivement il faut
que l'heureux que le gouvernement se
réunissent aujourd'hui on l'a réglé une
première étape qui consistait donc avec
la démission du ministre de
l'information mais il ya également un
autre problème qui reste comme un noeud
pour que ce gouvernement se réunissent
c'est que en fait les partis chiites
mais également il ya des leaders
sunnites qui re qui en fait veulent le
départ du juge bitar qui est le juge
d'investigation d' enquête à charge est
justement de l'explosion afin de trouver
qui sont les responsables
de l'explosion au port de beyrouth donc
il ya également celui qui empêche pour
le moment le conseil des ministres est
très très rapidement le regard que vous
portez sur les contrats passés
par la france avec notamment à abu dhabi
80 rafale vendus et notamment les
contrats avec l'arabie saoudite est ce
que c'est bon ça pour la stabilité du
moyen orient
vous savez c'est un succès commercial
pour la france après sûr on peut avoir
les pensées sur le fait qu'effectivement
est ce que tout ça ça ça rentre pas dans
une espèce de guerre froide qui se joue
aujourd'hui entre d'un côté les pays
sunnites comme l'arabie saoudite les
émirats arabes unis et les impayés chic
environ il ya cette guerre froide qui a
commencé depuis 2003 où on voit que sans
se confronter directement lieu
c'est-à-dire la rhapsodie désignera au
mieux et se battre sur d'autres terrains
comme par exemple la syrie l'irak ou
même le liban ou le yemen et donc il est
il est important aussi donc baisser
d'arriver à certaines pacification de la
région en essayant de rapprocher les
iraniens les saoudiens
ratti les égyptiens etc
mais encore une fois il est très
important que le liban qu lui reste en
dehors des divisions des guerre froide
qu'elle qui sont entre ces pays là parce
que le liban est un pays fragile où il
ya des communautés sunnite et chiite
communauté chrétienne est donc cet
équilibre fragile ne peut pas résister
s'il n'y a pas de neutralité donc cette
neutralité c'est vraiment la clé de la
solution au liban merci beaucoup à vous
michel fayyad analystes politiques et
financiers
et en marge de cette visite de groupes
français et européens ont conclu des
accords avec le royaume d'eolia et
airbus le montant des transactions n'a
pas été dévoilé on connaît par ailleurs
celui du contrat signé hier entre
dassault aviation et les émirats arabes
unis un contrat d'armement d'au moins 15
milliards d'euros portant notamment sur
des rafales a de quoi faire bondir les
ong une partie de l'opposition les
explications d'adrien fonteneau
il ya ce contrat conclu avec les émirats
arabes unis
cette rencontre ce samedi avec les
dirigeants saoudiens et les polémiques
qui les entoure après la vente de 80
rafale et avant un entretien stratégique
en arabie saoudite
emmanuel macron est pointée du doigt en
cause ses relations et partenariats avec
des pays accusés de crimes de guerre
soyons honnête avec moi même je ne
cautionne rien je suis exigeant nous
continuons de dire ensuite qui peut
penser une seule seconde qu'on aide le
liban qu'on préserve la paix la
stabilité au moyen-orient en oeuvre si
on dit on ne parle plus à l'arabie
saoudite est ce que la france peut
rester passif dans la région non je ne
crois pas je pense que nous sommes une
grande puissance d' équilibre comme j'ai
eu l'occasion de le dire notre rôle
c'est d'agir et donc le partenariat
stratégique
qu'elle nous donnons plus de force et de
contenus avec les émirats arabes unis il
sut cet agenda et stabilité dans la
région lutte contre tous les extrêmes
lutte contre le terrorisme et
coopération très concrètes sur les
situations sensibles une situation
sensible c'est ce que connaît le yémen
depuis 2014 soutenu par l'iran les
rebelles houthi font face à des
autorités yéménites
appuyé par une coalition entre l'arabie
saoudite et les émirats arabes unis deux
pays du moyen-orient dont la france est
rapproché économiquement ces dernières
heures et militairement déjà depuis le
début du conflit comme le révèlent des
documents classés confidentiel défense
des notes rédigées par le secrétariat
général de la défense et de la sécurité
nationale un organisme placé sous
l'autorité de matignon dévoile que
l'état français a autorisé en 2016 la
livraison de près de cent cinquante
mille au but à l'arabie saoudite et aux
émirats arabes unis tout en sachant que
ces munitions servirait dans la guerre
au yémen ce vendredi à paris une plainte
a été déposée au nom d'une ong yéménite
contre les princes héritiers d'arabie
saoudite et des émirats arabes unis
accusés d' alliance avec al qaïda
selon l'onu la guerre au yémen aura
causé la mort directe et indirecte 2 377
mille personnes d'ici la fin de l'année
vladimir poutine et et joe biden devrait
se parler par visioconférence mardi une
annonce du kremlin les deux chefs d'état
devraient évoquer le dossier ukrainien
c'est un dossier qui était à l'ordre du
jour durant la semaine à lors d'une
réunion tendue de l'ol c'est eux
l'organisation pour la sécurité et la
coopération en europe l'occident quand
une future agression russe en ukraine ce
que la russie a dément elle a appelé ces
derniers jours à un dialogue
diplomatique a le dossier ukrainien et
les projets d'expansion de l'otan à
l'aise ce sera donc au coeur du rendez
vous entre les deux puissances sachez
d'ailleurs que dans les années 1990
l'otan avait exprimé ne pas avoir
l'intention d'intégrer les pays d'europe
de l'est dans son organisation retour
avec vera goffman sur une page de
l'histoire qui pourrait bien se réécrit
dans les années à venir
les politiciens ont la mémoire courte
c'est bien connu côté occidental par
exemple on n'a strictement aucun
souvenir de soi disant promesse de non
expansion de le temps à l'ess des
promesses qui aurait été fait il ya
trente ans un échange du relâchement de
l'étreinte soviétique sur les pays du
pacte de varsovie
tout d'abord l'otan n'a jamais donné de
garanties à gorbatchev ou à un autre
dirigeant soviétique concernant le fait
que l'organisation n'aurait pas de
nouveaux membres ensuite la simple idée
que certains alliés importants donnerait
ce jour de carinthie ils violent d'une
certaine manière quelques principes
vraiment fondamentaux
ainsi aucune garantie de ce type n'a été
donnée
les gens disent qu'il est très
provocateur vis-à-vis de la russie que
la lettonie est décidé de devenir membre
de l'otan je veux dire cela suppose que
la lettonie ne peut pas faire ce qu'elle
veut parce qu'elle voisine de la russie
et il s'agit là de la vieille façon de
considérer le droit des grandes
puissances et de décider ce que leur
petit voisin peut faire
sauf que à les archives américaines elle
se souvient très bien des mots du
secrétaire d'état de l'époque james
baker pas un pouce vers l'est disait-il
le 9 février 1990 lors de sa rencontre
avec mikhaïl gorbatchev et il était loin
d'être le seul prenons le secrétaire
général de l'otan de 1988 à 1994
l'allemand manfred burner
monsieur verner a souligné que le
conseil de l'otan et lui-même étaient
opposés à l'expansion de l'otan
treize des seize membres de
l'organisation soutiennent ce point de
vue dans un avenir proche lors de sa
rencontre avec lech walesa et le
dirigeant roumain iliescu il s'opposa à
l'adhésion de la pologne et de la
roumanie à l'otan comme il l'a déjà fait
pour la hongrie et la tchécoslovaquie
nous ne devons pas permettre a déclaré
monsieur werner l'isolément de l'urss
vis-à-vis de la communauté européenne ou
le premier ministre britannique
manager excusez du peu dont les propos
sont rapportés par l'ambassadeur de
grande-bretagne à moscou rodrigue bright
lights
lors de la réunion avec les responsables
militaires qui a suivi le maréchal iazov
a exprimé ses inquiétudes quant à
l'intérêt des dirigeants d'europe de
l'est pour une adhésion à l'otan dans
son journal bref wait écrit major lui
assure que rien de tel ne se produira
vous en voulez encore alors voyons donc
ce qu'en disait un dietrich genscher
ministre des affaires étrangères et
vice-chancelier allemand révélé par ce
câble confidentiel des classes et de
l'ambassade américaine à destination de
james baker
d'un autre côté guen cher précise que
les changements en europe de l'est et le
processus d'unification allemande ne
doivent pas débouché sur une atteinte
aux intérêts de sécurité soviétique par
conséquent l'otan devrait exclure une
extension de son territoire vers l'est
c'est à dire en le rapprochant des
frontières soviétique guen cher ajoute
que la considération concernant
l'inclusion de la partie de l'allemagne
qui constitue aujourd'hui la rda dans
les structures militaires de l'otan
bloquerait le rapprochement allemagne
allemagne et des documents comme ça il y
en a plein encore les férus d'histoire
peut faire le tour des archives de la
sécurité nationale à l'université de
george washington c'est extrêmement
instructives mais visiblement personne a
le temps on ya mis les pieds depuis des
lustres et puis vous savez ce que c'est
elle les paroles s'envolent les écrits
restent c'est sans doute pour cela que
les autorités russes proposent
aujourd'hui pour désamorcer la crise
diplomatique actuelle de se mettre
d'accord par écrit sur cette question de
l'expansion de l'otan vers l'est
le scénario cauchemardesque d'un
affrontement militaire qui a déjà connu
notre continent est de retour après la
fameuse double décision de l'otan
l'europe garde le silence le bourrage
militaire de l'ukraine continue
renforçant la détermination de kiev à
saboter les accords de minsk et
nourrissant l'illusion de la possibilité
d'une solution militaire au conflit je
tiens à ce que ce soit très clair la
transformation de nos pays voisins en
tête de pont en vue d'un affrontement
avec la russie le déploiement des forces
de l'otan à proximité immédiate de zone
stratégiquement importante pour notre
sécurité est catégoriquement
inacceptable il est temps de transformer
2 juste parole en garanties de sécurité
à long terme et juridiquement
contraignant on se demande bien ce qui
peut l'enquêté le temps ne se vend
tuerez pas dans de hasard deux
opérations militaires au risque de semer
le chaos enfin sauf si l'on met your
slaves ou afghans ou les biens et demain
et lors de la rencontre entre joe biden
et vladimir poutine il sera question
mardi d' notamment de la crise
migratoire à la frontière entre la
biélorussie et la pologne une source de
tension entre ces deux pays aient des
sanctions contre mixe aussi à des
sanctions notamment économiques de
plusieurs pays dont les états unis le
royaume uni et le canada elle concerne
également des individus et des
organisations proches du pouvoir
biélorusse en tout cas le kremlin les
juges il les victimes écoutez
nous condamnons fermement les nouvelles
mesures restrictives à l'encontre de la
biélorussie adopté simultanément ce 2
décembre par les états unis l'union
européenne le royaume uni et le canada
ces sanctions sont illégitimes
comme toute restriction imposée en
contournant le conseil de sécurité de
l'onu elles revêtent un caractère
inhumain en raison de leur impact
négatif sur la vie des citoyens
biélorusses ordinaire nous appelons les
états occidentaux à renoncer aux deux
poids deux mesures et à la politique de
pressions exercées par le biais de
sanctions illégitime ainsi qu'à faire
preuve d'une approche civilisé et à
entamer la résolution pratique de la
crise migratoire en coopération avec les
autorités de la république de
biélorussie
valérie pécresse pour terminer sera la
candidate l air à la présidentielle de
2000 22 en france elle a remporté cet
après-midi le vote des sympathisants du
parti face à eric ciotti avec plus de
60% des voix elle devient ainsi la
première femme investie par la droite à
l'élection présidentielle française on
l'écouté
votre confiance me va droit au coeur et
elle m'oblige
je mesure aussi l'audace qui est la
vôtre aujourd'hui pour la première fois
pour la première fois de son histoire le
parti du général de gaulle de georges
pompidou le jacques chirac le nicolas
sarkozy notre famille politique va se
doter d'une candidate à l'élection
présidentielle
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi on va se retrouver
dans une trentaine un des mines est
resté avec nous sur rt france
non
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il
n'ya pas une paix relative on sort du
qualité il est clair que tout le monde
attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il